one of our great allies
president Duda
prime minister Mr Prime Minister Mr
Mayor
to all the former ministers and
presidents
as well as Mayors and polish political
leaders from all across the country
thank you for welcoming back to Poland
you know it's nearly one year ago
nearly one year ago I spoke at the Royal
Castle here at Warsaw
just weeks after Vladimir Putin had
Unleashed his murderous assault on
Ukraine
foreign
key stands proud
crane being tested
the whole world faced the test for the
ages
Europe was being tested America was
being tested NATO is being tested all
democracies are being tested the
questions we Face were as simple as they
were profound would we respond
would we look the other way would it be
strong
would we the all of our allies would be
United or divided
one year later we know the answer
we did respond we would be strong we
would be United and the world would not
look the other way
[Applause]
we also face fundamental questions
about the commitment to the most basic
of principles
would we stand
up for the sovereignty of nations would
we stand up for the right of people to
live free from naked aggression
we stand up for democracy
one year later
we know the answers
yes we would stand up for sovereignty
and we did
yes we would stand up for the right of
people to live free from aggression and
we did
and we would stand up for democracy and
and yesterday I had the honor to stand
with president zielinski in cave to
declare that we will keep standing up
for these same things no matter what
[Applause]
when President Putin ordered his tanks
to roll in Ukraine he thought
we would roll over
he was wrong
you ranked the Ukrainian people are too
brave
America Europe a coalition of Nations
for the Atlantic to the Pacific we were
too Unified
democracy was too strong
instead of an easy Victory he perceived
and predicted Putin left
with burnout tanks and Russia's forces
and delay into in disarray
he thought he'd get the finalization of
NATO
instead he got the natoization of
Finland
and Sweden
he thought NATO would fracture and
divide
instead
NATO was more united and more unified
than ever than ever before
he thought he could weaponize energy
to crack your resolve Europe's resolve
instead we're working together to end
Europe's dependence on Russell Russian
fossil fuels
he thought autocrats like himself were
tough
and leaders of democracy were soft
and then he met the Iron Will of America
in the Nations everywhere that refused
to accept the world governed by fear and
force
he found himself at war with a nation
led by a man whose courage would be
forged in Fire and steel president
zielinski
President Putin
President Putin is confronted with
something today that he didn't think was
possible a year ago
the Democracy of the world have grown
stronger
not weaker
but the autocrats of the world have
grown weaker not stronger
because in the moments of great upheaval
and uncertainty
that knowing what you stand for is most
important and knowing who stands with
you makes all the difference
the people of Poland know that you know
that
in fact you know you know it better than
anyone here in Poland because that's
what solidarity means
through partition and oppression
when the beautiful City was destroyed
after the war saw Uprising during
decades under the Iron Fist of communist
rule Poland endured because you stood
together
That's How brave leaders of the
opposition and the people of Belarus
continue to fight for their democracy
that's how the resolve of moldovan
people
resolve the people on Dover to live in
Freedom
gained them Independence and put them on
the path to EU membership
president Sand Dune is here today I'm
not sure she is but I'm proud to stand
with you and the freedom loving people
of Moldova
give her a round of applause
[Applause]
one year and one year into this war
Putin no longer doubts the strength of
our coalition
but he still doubts our conviction
he doubts our staying power
he doubts our continues to Forfeit
Ukraine
he doubts with our NATO can remain
Unified
but there should be no doubt our support
for Ukraine will not waver NATO will not
be divided and we will not Tire
[Applause]
President Putin's craving lust for land
and power will fail
and the Ukrainian people's love for
their country will prevail
democracies the world will stand guard
over Freedom today tomorrow and forever
[Applause]
so that's what it's that's what's at
stake here freedom
that's the message I carried to Keith
yesterday
directly to the people of Ukraine
when president zielinski said he came to
the United States in December quote he
said this struggle
will Define the world and what our
children and grandchildren how they live
and then their children and
grandchildren
he wasn't only speaking about the
children and grandchildren of Ukraine
he was speaking about all of our
children and grandchildren yours and
mine
we're seeing again today with the people
of Poland and the people across Europe
saw for decades
appetites of the autocrac
cannot be appeased they must be opposed
autocrats only understand one word no no
no
you will not take my country
no you will not take my freedom no you
will not take my future
and I'll repeat tonight what I said last
year in the same place
a dictator
they're not rebuilding an Empire will
never be able to ease the people's love
of Liberty brutality
will never grind down the will of the
free
and Ukraine
Ukraine will never be a victory for
Russia never
[Applause]
for free people refuse to live in a
world of hopelessness and darkness
you know this has been an extraordinary
year in every sense
extraordinary brutality
from Russian forces and Mercenaries
they've committed to privities
crimes against humanity without shame or
compunction
they've targeted civilians with death
and destruction
used rape as a weapon of War
stolen Ukrainian children
an attempt in an attempt to steal
Ukraine's future
bomb train stations maternity hospital
schools and orphanages
no one
no one can turn away their eyes from the
atrocities Russia is committing against
the Ukrainian people it's abhorrent it's
abhorrent
but extraordinarily
as well
has been the response of the Ukrainian
people and the world
one year after the bombs began to fall
Russian tanks rolled into Ukraine
Ukraine is still independent and free
from Pearson to car keys Ukrainian
Fighters have reclaimed their land
more than 50 percent of the territory
Russia held last year
the blue and the yellow flag of Ukraine
proudly ways once again
president zielinski still leads the
Democratic elected government that
represents the will of the Ukrainian
people
and the world has already voted multiple
times
including the United Nations General
Assembly to condemn Russians aggression
and supported just peace
each time in the U.N that vote has been
overwhelming
in October
143 Nations the United Nations condemned
Russia's illegal annexation only four
for the entire U.N voted with Russia
four
so tonight
I speak once more to the people of
Russia
the United States and the nations of
Europe do not seek to control or destroy
Russia
the West Was Not plotting to attack
Russia as Putin said today
and millions of Russian citizens who
only want to live in peace with their
neighbors are not the enemy
this war was never a necessity
it's a tragedy
President Putin chose this war
every day the war continues is his
choice
he could end the war with the word
it's simple
if Russia stopped invading Ukraine it
would end the war
if Ukraine stop defending itself against
Russia would be the end of Ukraine
that's why together
we're making sure Ukraine can defend
itself
the United States has assembled a
worldwide Coalition of more than 50
Nations
to get critical weapons and supplies
to the brave Ukrainian fighters on the
front lines air defense systems
artillery ammunition tanks armored
vehicles
the European Union and its member states
have stepped up with unprecedented
commitment to Ukraine not just in
security assistance but economic and
humanitarian Refugee insistence and so
much more
to all of you here tonight
take a moment
and I'm serious when I say this turn on
look turn around and look at one another
look at what you've done so far
Poland is hosting more than 1.5 million
refugees from this war God bless you
full of generosity your willingness to
open your hearts and your homes is
extraordinary
in the American people are united in our
resolve as well
all across my country
and big cities and small towns
Ukrainian Flags fly from American homes
over the past year Democrats and
Republicans in our United States
Congress have come together to stand for
freedom
that's who Americans are and that's what
Americans do
the world was also coming together to
address the global Fallout
from President Putin's War
Putin tried to starve the world
blocking the portion of the Black Sea to
stop Ukraine from exporting its grain
exacerbating the global food crisis that
hit developing nations in Africa
especially hard
instead the United States and the G7 and
partners around the world answered the
call with historic commitments to
address the crisis and to bolster Global
Food Supplies
and this week
my wife Jill Biden is traveling to
Africa to help bring attention to this
critical issue
our commitment is to the people of
Ukraine
and the future of Ukraine a Ukraine is
free
Sovereign and Democratic
that was a dream of those who declared
Ukraine's Independence more than 30
years ago
who led the orange Revolution
and the revolution of dignity
who braved ice and fire in the badon
and the Heavenly Hunters who died there
and those who continue still to root out
kremlin's efforts to corrupt coerce and
control
it's a dream for those Ukrainian
Patriots
who fought for years against Russia's
aggressions in the dombas
and the heroes
who've given everything given their
lives
with the service of the Beloved Ukraine
I was honored to visit the memorial in
Kiev yesterday to pay tribute to the
sacrifice of those who lost their lives
standing alongside president zielinski
the United States and our partners stand
with Ukraine's teachers as Hospital
staff as emergency responders
the workers and cities
across Ukraine are fighting to keep the
power on
in the face of Russia's cruel
bombardment
we stand with the millions of refugees
of this war
who found a welcome in Europe and the
United States particularly here in
Poland
Ordinary People all across Europe
did whatever they could to help and
continue to do so polish businesses
Civil Society cultural leaders including
the first lady of Poland who was here
tonight have led with the heart and
determination showcasing all that's good
about the human Spirit Madam first lady
we love you thank you all
I'll never forget last year visiting
with refugees from Ukraine who had just
arrived in Warsaw seen their faces
exhausted and Afraid holding their
children so close
wherein they may never see their fathers
their husbands their brothers or sisters
again
and that darkest moment through lives
you the people of Poland offered them
safety and Light
you embrace them you literally embrace
them I watched I watched the looks on
their faces
meanwhile
together we made sure that Russia is
paying the price for its abuses we
continue to maintain the largest
sanctioned regime ever imposed in any
country in history
and we're going to announce more
sanctions this week together with our
partners
well hold accountable those who are
responsible for this war
and will seek Justice for the war crimes
and crimes against humanity continuing
to be committed by the Russians
you know
there is much for us to be proud of over
the all that we have achieved together
this past year
but we have to be honest and clear-eyed
as we look at the year ahead
the defense of freedom is not the work
of a day or of a year
it's always difficult
It's always important
as Ukraine continues to defend itself
against the Russian Onslaught and launch
counter-offensive of its own
there will continue to be hard and very
bitter days
victories and tragedies
but Ukraine is still for the fight ahead
in the United States together with our
allies and partners are going to
continue to have Ukraine's back as it
defends itself
next year
I will host every member of NATO
for our 2024 Summit in the United States
together
will celebrate the 75th anniversary of
the strongest defensive Alliance in the
history of the world NATO
and
and let there be no doubt
commitment of the United States to our
NATO alliance and Article 5 is Rock
Solid
[Music]
and every member of NATO knows it and
Russia knows it as well
an attack against one is attack against
all it's a sacred oath
[Applause]
sacred oath to the vent every inch of
NATO territory
over the past year the United States has
come together with our allies and
partners in an extraordinary coalition
to stand against Russian aggression
but the work in front of us is not just
what we're against
it's about what we're for
what kind of world do we want to build
we need to take the strength and
capacity of this Coalition and apply it
to lifting up lifting up the lives of
people everywhere improving health
growing Prosperity preserving the plan
of building peace and security
treating everyone with dignity and
respect that's our responsibility
the democracies of the world have to
deliver it for our people
As We Gather tonight
the world in my view as an at an
inflection point the decisions we make
over the next five years or so are going
to determine and shape our lives for
decades to come
that's true for Americans it's true for
the people of the world
and while decisions
are ours to make now
the principles and the stakes are
eternal
the choice between chaos and stability
between building and destroying between
hope and fear
between democracy that lifts up the
human spirit
and the brutal hand of the dictator who
crushes it
between nothing less than limitation
and possibilities
the kind of possibilities that come
when people who live not in captivity
but in Freedom
freedom
Freedom there is no sweeter word than
freedom there is no nobler goal than
Freedom there's no higher aspiration
than freedom
Americans know that and you know it
and all that we do now must be done so
our children and grandchildren will know
it as well freedom
the enemy of the Tyrant and the hope of
the Brave and the truth of the ages
freedom
stand with us
we will stand with you
let us move forward with faith and
conviction and with an abiding
commitment to be allies
not of Darkness but of light
notable oppression but of liberation
not of captivity but yes of freedom
may God bless you all may God protect
our troops
and may God bless the heroes of Ukraine
and all those who didn't defend Freedom
around the world thank you Poland thank
you thank you thank you for what you're
doing
whoa
[Applause]